look whether a person died in a hospital
or died in a nursing home
it's the people died
we're below the national average in
number of deaths in nursing homes
but who cares they died
yeah they died and my next guest cares
and maybe
you should care too we're breaking news
tonight from the new york post
governor andrew cuomo's secretary has
now admitted that they covered up the
state's
nursing home death toll that stunning
admission
made on a call with state leaders from
the democrat party
where his secretary apologized for the
cover-up and then blamed president trump
for the decision to withhold those
numbers
janis dean joins me now the peerless
meteorologist
new york times best-selling author of
the forthcoming book
make your own sunshine and the next
governor
of new york uh janice janice
this was a this was a tragedy
for your in-laws uh because it should
have been their 60th wedding anniversary
right now and instead your father-in-law
and your mother-in-law
died within a few days of each other and
uh andrew cuomo it's almost as if
uh you as you tweeted the other day it
looks as if there might be a reckoning
for him over this
this is the biggest bombshell that we
have had so far
uh we had a trickling in of the numbers
we knew the numbers were much bigger
than the governor was admitting
so over 15 000 residents died from
getting coveted in their nursing homes
they just admitted that they put over 9
000 infected patients into nursing homes
and now the biggest bombshell coming
from the new york post
uh that his secretary melissa de rosa
admitted that they covered it all
up and and i don't think you can
overstate the tragedy
of this that i know after you tweeted
about your in-laws
i noticed uh it was a kind of mini trend
that the husband would die on the
tuesday
and the wife would die on the friday and
someone such as yourself has
to have that terrible thing where you've
got to explain to your kid that uh
grandma's died and then a few years
a few days later that grandpa's died and
yet we've got all these restrictions on
restaurants
on every other aspect of life and the
people who were most
vulnerable andrew cuomo failed to
protect on an horrific scale
absolutely and it wasn't just him there
were other governors other democratic
governors that did the same thing
putting covet positive patients into
nursing homes
newsom uh whitmer wolff
and murphy and cuomo five of them
put covet positive patients into nursing
homes yeah
let's be bipartisan and throw in that
so-called republican in massachusetts uh
too because uh he did that uh as as well
as well for a while i mean do you do he
said he became a hero
to the left in this country cuomo and he
still
thinks this can bounce off him
it can't not now we have an admission
and i would like to thank whoever that
democratic lawmaker was that was the
leak
yesterday that gave us that information
because i believe all of them should go
to jail
do you think that will come to that that
there will be
criminal charges against new york's
administration
i think they have to do something there
has to be an independent bipartisan
investigation now with subpoena power
we need to see these people on the stand
with a jury
with us the people that lost our loved
ones
in the audience to see them tell the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
because justice needs to be served we
don't have
our loved ones here today but by god i
am here to be a voice for all of them
and i
want justice the celebrity class has
mocked you
on on twitter janice they're saying
you're just
like a weather girl you don't know what
you're talking about
and why do you keep going on in it
you're determined to keep going on about
this
it's personal i have never been a
political person in my entire life
it affected my family i'm speaking on
behalf of them
and it was it's their 60th wedding
anniversary today mark
and the angels won
yeah they they thank you for putting it
like that janice uh
that's beautiful and you are mostly
sunny as your best-selling book
said and we're going to have you on back
to talk about your uh
your new book thank you very much janice
dean you can see her
on fox and friends tomorrow morning